this is an introduction to the new 3d
printing functionality of version 11 the
main purpose of the 3d printing
functionality is an easy workflow for
immediate 3d printing let's start with
the Triceratops from our 3d geometry
collection and immediately send it for
printing good-news function print out 3d
automatically connects to your local
printer if you do not have a printer or
need higher quality it can upload models
to an online 3d printing service such as
AI materialize the 3d printing workflow
can be summarized in three easy steps
modeling analyzing and printing there
are several different ways to model an
object in version 11 a large volume of
curated 3d printable objects is already
available for example the new property
region returns a geometric 3d printable
object easily import a model from a 3d
repository such as Thingiverse version
11 supports the import and export of 3d
geometry of all standard formats you can
create 3d printable plots with the plot
themes fixed surface and filled surface
the expression below generates a non
printable surface without thickness a 3d
printable solid is created by including
the plot theme fixed surface the
plucking filled surface fills the space
between the surface and a flat base
algorithmically generated you metrics
and 3d printable models start with an
image generate a mesh using image mesh
extrude it with region product for a 3d
printable model analyze models by
returning specific properties let's
start with a space shuttle model compute
its volume find the mass of the model in
aluminum estimate the cost at forty five
cents per surface area check this
of a box needed for shipment 3d printing
does not always work as expected model
flaws such as holes tiny faces and
overlapping faces may occur with CAD or
3d modeling software the unprinted model
collection you have accumulated over the
years may also be faulty version 11
integrates fully automated detection of
mesh defects and provides repair
functionality the new function shell
region helps optimize the amount of
printing material which reduces the cost
the following example uses shell region
to create a hollows Triceratops model
the volume is reduced and ready to print
for more advanced use the numerical
differential equation solving
capabilities in the Wolfram language can
help detect issues with your designs
before undertaking the expense of 3d
printing let's find this dress areas of
a crankshaft find the material
properties of steel using Wolfram Alpha
perform a stress analysis and visualize
the deformation version 11 provides
fully integrated capabilities to
directly print 3d geometric models with
an online printing service or your own
printer the highly automated function
print out 3d allows direct connection to
a local printer 3d geometry file formats
such as STL can also be used send a
model to an online 3d printing surface
shape ways I materialize sculpt do 3d
hubs in version 11 the process of
modeling and printing a 3d object is
quick and easy start now to build
incredible 3d objects to print and share
with your colleagues and Friends